[Music]
[Music]
my name is thomas rago
and i am co-owner of ringo brothers shoe
and leather repair our team is now going
to walk you through the restoration and
repair of a hermes birkin bag that's
valued in excess of ten thousand dollars
we received the bag and immediately we
realized the bag needs new tubing in the
handles the corners are worn
it needs new feet
and it needs color restoration
[Music]
first off we are now going to give this
bag to luis he is going to begin the
process of deconstructing the bag
we do that by opening up the bag pulling
the binding out of the inside of the bag
pulling the stitches out one stitch at a
time so that we don't damage the
existing stitch holes
using a very sharp razor knife we need
to take all four sides of the bag off to
access the piping on the bottom of the
bag
we've got the bag apart now but we need
to get the excess glue and all the
stitching out so we are going to take a
piece of rubber and we are going to rub
off that excess glue
and pull out the old stitches so that
when we re-glue this bag it holds
upon taking off the old feet we see that
we need to make the holes larger
to fit the new feet so what we're going
to need to do is take a punch and punch
that hole
slightly bigger than it is now
[Music]
the tubing inside of those handles are
plastic the person may have weighted it
so over time plastic breaks down it
broke we need to replace
that tubing on the inside
of the handles
the only way that we're going to access
that tubing is to take the handle apart
so very carefully
with a knife we need to take out each
stitch
one by one
so now we have the tubing out
we cut and measured the new tubing
and we need to lay it on the existing
handle
close it
and then we need to restitch that
tubing back into the handle and that's
done
one stitch at a time
by hand
[Music]
the piping leather is damaged
it needs to be replaced
fortunately we have leather that is the
same as the leather that came off of the
bag but it's too thick
we have a skiving machine a machine that
splits that leather
makes it thinner
but even so after we thin it we have to
take a razor sharp knife and even make
it thinner
after we take the now very thin leather
and wrap it around the new plastic
piping
we need to clamp the edges to close it
hermes bags
are made one at a time and
by hand so we are going to have to take
a lot of time to bring this bag back to
the condition it was in when it was
first bought
the bag is inside out we can see the
same stitch holes
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to stitch the two sides
after we do the two sides
we're going to sew the top
and then finally
we're going to sew around the bottom
where we put the new piping in
now that we have the structure of the
bag back to where it was we have to
think about cleaning and conditioning
and recoloring this bag it's faded the
color is just not there
before we can re-dye this bag we have to
make sure that all the surface dirt is
off
if there is any
polish or conditioner on it we need to
take that off so that when we put the
dye on this bag it adheres
we are using a cleaning solution and we
take a very soft finger brush
and we scrub the bag to remove all the
excess dirt and film and polish that we
need to get off
after we clean it we're going to take a
clean cloth and wipe it off
what we need to do now is we need to
match the color we'll look on the bag
we'll look for a spot that really looks
like the bag did look like 10 years ago
and then we will mix color water-based
paint to match that part of the bag
the mixing of the dye
is all done by eye under the correct
lighting depending on the color the guy
may have to mix the dies three or four
times before he's satisfied that he got
close to the original color
depending on the texture of the bag that
will determine what applicator we will
use to put the die on the bag
[Music]
now that we have the die on the bag
there are some finishing touches we need
to do that really makes the job we need
to re-edge the handles and we need to
re-edge the top of the bag
now the edging on the handle and the top
of the bag not the same color as the bag
so we have to go back again to mix the
color to match the original edging that
was on the bag
[Music]
[Music]
the dye is dried we need to condition
the bag and the reason why we're
conditioning it is to hold that die
that along with resealing the bag is
going to make certain that this bag
stays looking good for years to come
[Music]
myself my team
were really proud of the way this bag
came out and we only wish that we could
see the expression on the client's face
when she opens up the bag and looks at
it
it really is a rewarding process
[Music]